Rosi you bored you brought back your
talk show online on March 22nd I didn't
understand this whole concept in other
words you went and said anyone who loved
my old talk show I'm gonna bring it back
and somehow you ended up raising six
hundred thousand dollars for the actors
fun how does that how does that all
happen I don't understand what that is
Eric Bergen who's a wonderful actor he's
been on Broadway he's also was in madam
secretary all those years he called me
up and I know him his mom lives real
close to me where I used to live in
Nyack and he called me up and said
listen you don't have to do anything
would sit in front of your computer I'll
handle everything I'm gonna announce it
as the revival of Rosie O'Donnell show
one night only and we'll get all these
Broadway people to come on and you just
do it from your garage and I saw you
must have been in heaven you did wear a
bra for it no I haven't had a bra on
since colvett honey don't you feel for
if you're bringing back something as
important as the Rosie O'Donnell show
you should have least put on a bra no no
bra no makeup it was Mike ovid
performance we asked people to give
money and they they some gave money on
the air and some donated privately I
assumed but we raised six hundred
thousand and people were like what what
are you actors to cheer yourselves well
it's not just for actors it's for stage
hands it's for Usher's it's for everyone
so Rosie did you do would you continue
doing the Rosie O'Donnell show on Sunday
nights let's say if you had a sponsor
and you know somebody sponsor you didn't
you know maybe you started up again
online yeah the only way I would do it
is online because that was so fun for me
and it I don't know what the world is
gonna look like when this is done I
don't know if over produced shows with
you know big celebrities is gonna be the
thing that people are looking for after
all of it you know but I would love to
do that our we got a sponsor I do it
every Sunday night and raise money for
different charities
you
you